We humans are unable to experience the true nature of the universe unfiltered
our senses and brains can only process a fraction of the world,
so we have to use concepts and tools to learn about the true nature of reality.
Technological progress not only widened our knowledge about the universe,
it also made us aware of unsettling possibilities.
In the future.
It might become possible to simulate entire universities,
but if this is an option,
how can we know that it's not already happened?
What if we are not creators,
but creations?
Is it possible that we are not real and we don't even know it?
If our current understanding of physics is correct,
then it's impossible to simulate the whole universe with its trillions and
trillions of things,
but we don't actually need to anyway.
We only need enough universe to fool the inhabitance of our simulation into
thinking that they real who needs billions of galaxies.
We only need the space.
Our subjects are allowed to explore.
The best universe can just be a flat projection and they would have no way to
know.
What about small things like cells or bacteria?
We don't really need them.
When you use a microscope,
once you see could be instantly created.
Same with atoms.
The chair you're sitting on right now does not need to be stimulated with
quadrillions of atoms.
We just need the outermost layer of it.
It might be empty and size until you decide to break it open.
Your body might feel like it's filled with bubby things,
but it might be empty until you open it.
The minimum requirement for our simulation is only the consciousness of Allen
virtual humans.
Our subjects just need to think the simulation is real.
Okay,
so,
oh,
we being simulated.
Well maybe,
but there are a few conditions that need to be mass.
Obviously we have no authority over this topic,
so please take everything we say with a grain of salt based on a modified
version of the original simulation argument by Nick Bostrom.
We have five assumptions for you.
If they're true,
you,
dear viewer,
are living in a simulation assumption.
One,
it's possible to simulate consciousness.
Nobody knows what consciousness is.
For the sake of argument.
Let's assume that you could generate consciousness by simulating a brain.
Brains are pretty complex.
If you count every interaction between Synapsis is one operation,
your brain runs at about 10 to the power of 17 or 100 million billion operations
per second.
Let's generously assume we need 10 to the power of 20 operations does simulate
one second of human consciousness.
Well,
we don't want to simulate just one human.
We want to see me like all of human history at once,
so we can skip around.
Let's say we want us to be like 200 billion humans with an average lifespan of
50 years.
One year has 30 million seconds times 50 years times 200 billion humans times 10
to the power of 20 operations.
So we need a computer able to handle a million trillion,
trillion,
trillion operations per second more operations than there are stars in the
observable universe.
The computer like this is just impossible,
except maybe it isn't.
The assumption to technological progress will not stop anytime soon.
If we assume the technological progress continues in a similar fashion as it has
so far,
then there might be galaxy spanning civilizations with unlimited computer power
at some point.
Beings on a technology level so advanced that we could barely distinguish them
from God's a computer that can handle a million,
trillion,
trillion operations is serious business,
but there are actually concepts for computers which could handle this.
The matryoshka brain is a theoretical mega structure made up of billions of
parts orbiting a star feeding on his radiation.
They or of this scale would have enough power to simulate many thousands if not
millions of humanities at the same time.
The technologies like high end future quantum computers might lower the size
drastically,
so it might be possible to do this with a structure the size of a large city or
even smaller,
but only if they're still somewhat around to build the computer
assumption.
Three advanced civilizations don't destroy themselves.
If there is a point at which all civilizations destroyed themselves,
this whole discussion ends here.
Looking into space,
you'd expect to universe filled with millions of alien civilizations,
but we see nobody.
The reason for this might be great filters.
Great filters are barriers.
Life has to overcome like nuclear war,
asteroid climate change or a black hole generator.
If life is inherently self destructive,
then there are no simulations.
We explain this in more detail in our family paradox.
Video
assumption for super advanced civilizations want to run simulations.
When we speak of post human civilizations,
we don't know what we're dealing with.
To think we know what beings as powerful as gods want is pretty arrogant.
Imagine the smartest and on earth living next to an amusement park.
It's curious about what humans are up to so you try to explain.
Unfortunately the aunt just doesn't understand the concept of rollercoasters and
standing in lines and holidays and fun.
It doesn't make sense to an aunt living and and life.
It's the same with us and a post human being compared to them.
We are ants running simulations for fun or science might be an absurdly stupid
ideas of them but if they do want to run simulations for whatever reasons and
assumptions one to three are true to,
then the chances are not zero that you are living inside a simulation assumption
five f there are a lot of simulations.
You are probably inside a simulation.
If there are simulated civilizations,
it's likely that there are a lot of them.
After all,
we assume the post human beings have access to practically unlimited computing
power.
So if they run simulations,
it would be convenient to run millions or even billions of them.
If there are billions of simulated universes,
there are probably trillions and trillions of simulated conscious beings,
which would mean that the vast majority of all conscious beings that we'll ever
have existed,
oh,
simulate it.
So for every conscious being made a flesh,
a billion simulated ones,
yeah,
exist.
Since we have no way of knowing if we are simulated or not.
In this case,
the chances of you being one of the 999,999,999 simulator ones are pretty high.
So what you consider reality might not be real at all.
You really might be simulated.
All of this is based on a lot of assumptions that we can't really test right
now.
So many scientists disagree with this whole thought experiment.
So don't burn your house down to test if there will be glitches.
If you are simulated.
Not that much changes for you.
You might be on a small planet speeding through eternal nothingness or a
simulation and side computer.
Your existence does not become more or less scary and bizarre.
All we can hope to do is try to live good lives and have a good time and hope
that if we actually are simulations in a supercomputer,
nobody trips over the power cable.
Oh,
oh,
oh no.
I think I just unplugged the simulation,
but what if that doesn't matter?
What if we are in one right now?
What if you are simulated
j covert at least or three is looking into that.
Click here to watch his video and subscribe to his channel.
Why are you still here?
Go over to the source.
Three,
watch the video and subscribe.
We promise it's worth your time.